hola mo sapienzapians
mi nombre es aid badwan
y ahora probablemente te estés preguntando
por qué este tipo raro que acaba de llamarme
homo sapiens sapiens usa estos
brazaletes con luces brillantes
y no te preocupes, llegaremos a eso, pero para
empezar  esta charla quiero que se tome
un momento
y se
pregunte cómo imagina que será el futuro
tómese su
tiempo es el futuro de la humanidad lo que está imaginando
y creo que es muy importante
pensar en ello seriamente porque el
futuro es solo lo que nosotros, las
personas  crear
y no podemos crear
lo que no podemos imaginar
cuando hago esta pregunta las
respuestas típicas son los tipos de robots de servicio que
toman pedidos en el restaurante
o revisan una escena en el hotel
gracias inube eso será todo por hoy
eres  bienvenido zade siempre a tu
servicio
lo que sea
clonar autos voladores en
realidades alternativas como en la matriz de la película
podemos concluir entonces
que el futuro que la mayoría de los humanos
imaginamos es en realidad solo nuestro pasado
y ya está en i  Este es el camino para la adopción masiva,
quiero decir
que acabas de ver a mi amigo robótico
y estoy bastante seguro de que todos recordamos a nuestro
viejo amigo de los años 90,
Dolly,
el barco payaso.
el laboratorio que
creó esta tecnología cuando estaba
investigando en los estados unidos
nuestra empresa en méxico está imprimiendo
prótesis robóticas utilizadas por ciberhumanos
que los controlan con sus mentes a
través de sus ondas cerebrales la
humanidad también está creando
bebés de bioingeniería
más inteligentes y resistentes a las
enfermedades  alfas para los lectores de un
mundo feliz de aldos
huxley ya
se habrán dado cuenta de que esta conferencia
no es la típica charla de ted
ya que en realidad la está
dando un robot
pero quiero decir que no estoy hablando de la
entidad física que acaba de reemplazarme  en
su pantalla ya que los robots no
necesariamente necesitan cuerpos humanoides el
guión de esta charla en realidad fue
creado en parte por un robot
estas palabras a  son los conocimientos de un
algoritmo entrenado al leer los
discursos que he dado en el pasado escribiendo
algo que suena exactamente como lo que
voy a decir mientras no lo he dicho todavía
en este mundo virtual mi cuerpo robótico se
conoce como un avatar y  Puedo hacer
cualquier cosa que se te ocurra y también
controlar mi entorno, como dar un
paseo en los autos voladores que están encima de mí,
así que, ¿qué piensas de mi nuevo cuerpo?
No mentiré, se siente extraño volver a ser
humano porque otro robot está usando
inteligencia artificial para rastrear mis
expresiones faciales calcularlas y
superponerlas en una versión digital
de mí mismo y todo sucede en
tiempo real mi traje de captura de movimiento está
digitalizando mi cuerpo y mis
manos es por eso que tengo sensores inerciales en
todo mi cuerpo recopilando datos y
simulando  mis movimientos en mi esqueleto virtual de
esta manera puedo habitar
cuerpos infinitos en mundos infinitos hay múltiples formas
de presentarme en el mundo virtual
, como usar escaneo 3D
donde con una mezcla  Gracias al reconocimiento de patrones de las cámaras
y la velocidad de los láseres que
rebotan en la persona u objeto deseado
, podemos crear esa malla 3D y no la
textura de mi piel en la parte
superior. En realidad, es la misma tecnología que
usamos para escanear a nuestros pacientes para crear
prótesis personalizadas con perfecta
ajustar y hacer coincidir el tamaño de otras extremidades
, trabajamos sobre sus cuerpos virtuales y
luego
los traemos de vuelta al mundo físico
mediante el uso de impresión 3D de
todos modos, ahora mismo estoy más interesado en
combinar los mundos virtual y físico
en uno
y las posibilidades que esto presenta.
porque en este momento estamos rompiendo la
barrera que separaba los bits y los átomos
convirtiéndolos en un concepto borroso para los
humanos que se pueden
intercambiar de uno
a otro,
un concepto que me gusta llamar
bytones
y bueno, todo esto puede parecer solo
imágenes entretenidas como las que
ven.  en películas o videojuegos, esta
tecnología en realidad tiene implicaciones más amplias
porque ahora me ves moviendo los labios
pero lo que estás escuchando no es mi
voz  pero otro robot y un ai entrenan
escuchándome hablar como lo hago
si me vuelvo virtual,
este robot permitirá que otra persona posea
mi cuerpo virtual y hable en mi nombre
usando mi voz y mi cuerpo o que alguien
podría ser solo otro robot
escribiendo su  propio guión
que ya no podemos saber no es del todo
conveniente si tienes una pareja celosa
o una carrera política esto se volverá
cada vez más relevante a medida que la interacción
entre las chicas se vuelve cada vez más
fácil hasta el punto en que no nos molestaremos en
tratar de adivinar si  estamos en un
entorno físico o virtual
después de hablar tanto sobre nuestro pasado
creo que está bastante claro que la tecnología
avanza rápido
nacimos en un mundo sin
acceso a Internet
y ahora tenemos todo esto
para darnos una idea de lo que podemos esperar a
continuación
así
que ahora que sabemos
dónde
estamos, finalmente es hora de comenzar a
imaginar
cómo será el futuro
,
ya que lo que imaginamos
es lo que hacemos, lo
que
significa permanecer, podríamos vivir para siempre,
todo lo que necesitamos en  el futuro
será la capacidad de copiar realmente un
cerebro completo
y almacenarlo en un cuerpo robótico o en un
mundo virtual
y hay muchas investigaciones prometedoras
sobre el tema que se están
realizando hoy en día.
Esta transición es quizás solo el siguiente
paso en la historia de siete millones
de años.  la evolución humana,
contrariamente a la creencia popular,
la evolución humana no se ha estancado
y, de hecho, es cada vez más rápida
en solo los últimos 100 años,
los cambios genéticos en humanos de todo el
mundo han expresado características
tales como siberianos con un metabolismo más rápido
que produce suficiente calor para prevenir la
congelación
o las personas.  de la tribu de la vagina que puede
sumergirse bajo el agua durante más de 12 minutos cuando
un humano promedio saludable puede contener la
respiración
durante solo un minuto,
pero de todos modos la
evolución pasada de moda
parece
demasiado lenta en
comparación con la ingeniería genética recientemente disponible
que podría expresar estas características
y otras todas  a la vez
e incluso más rápido
, incluso podríamos omitir el
botón generacional todo el tiempo
sin  ce, podemos biomentar
seres humanos ya existentes, incluso hoy en día
se considera que los amputados tienen una
ventaja injusta en los Juegos Olímpicos
porque es más fácil para ellos correr largas
distancias usando su prótesis en
lugar de ser considerados discapacitados
en la competencia, tienen ventajas sobre las
personas discapacitadas
que en  en este caso,
una mejor semántica será llamarlos
súper capacitados,
por lo que el siguiente paso de la evolución es un
cambio de paradigma
de cambiar nuestro entorno
para comenzar a cambiarnos a
nosotros mismos.
Este será el vínculo
del homo sapiens sapiens
al robot sapiens,
pero esto no será simplemente  dejar de tener
brazos
u ojos más fuertes con súper soles habilitados para ver
en la oscuridad
en el futuro
más memoria o incluso un pensamiento más rápido
podría volverse similar a comprar una
computadora portátil con un procesador más rápido y
memoria RAM expandida hoy
este futuro traerá algunos problemas por
sí solo
la desigualdad podría aumentar tan
exponencialmente como lo hace la tecnología
aumentando cada vez más
la brecha de ingresos en la población  ns,
dado que los humanos con mejores aumentos podrían tener
acceso a mejores trabajos que les darán
acceso a mejores actualizaciones con el tiempo,
y así sucesivamente,
esto también
funcionará al revés para los que
no son tan privilegiados
aún
no aumentando no parecería una
opción  en un mundo social rodeado de
súper capaces robo-sapiens
las viejas guerras genéticas de neandertales y
homo sapiens
nos decían eso
y de la misma manera
podemos entender que los robots no son
otras especies que nos van a reemplazar
sino el siguiente paso
en la  la evolución de las especies rawan
comenzando con un enlace cibernético
hasta la preservación robótica y virtual completa
de nuestra especie, lo que es aún
más complicado e incluso un dilema ético,
lo mismo se aplicará necesariamente
a nuestros hijos, ¿los padres amarán
que pierdan la oportunidad
de obtener mejores oportunidades?
les gustaría nacer más inteligentes o
resistentes a las enfermedades y si haríamos
lo mejor para ellos
y si estuviéramos dispuestos a aceptar la
evolución cómo d  diferente sería
tener un sol robótico tal vez en primer lugar por
nuestra total falta de capacidad para amarlos la
biología parece tener una triste
explicación del amor que sentimos por nuestros hijos
como una necesidad instintiva
de trascendencia
un deseo
que está cableado en  nuestra fisiología para
mantener vivos los orígenes en el planeta
antes de morir
y proteger esos genes
en forma de sol
incluso con nuestra propia vida
para que puedan crecer
de esta forma
imponerles la responsabilidad de
perpetuar el ciclo reproduciéndose
nuevamente
para la biología el
amor es  no es la razón
sino el egoísmo
por
eso esta idea de amor preferiría
romper mi ciclo personal
y
presente aceptando y siendo parte de la
transición a la era de los
robo-sapiens
ya que tal vez
las nuevas zonas de la humanidad
con sus cerebros superiores con
siempre-  una capacidad informática creciente y
sin las limitaciones biológicas
finalmente logrará responder a las
preguntas que nos han fascinado y
desplumado desde el comienzo de la
humanidad.
cuál es nuestro propósito
cuál es nuestro origen
y quiénes somos
humanos robots
o tal vez
solo polvo de estrellas de todos modos
justo antes de despedirme solo quiero
señalar
que puedo atribuirme el mérito de esta
charla
ya que es el resultado del
trabajo colectivo de  yo
y todos los robots que colaboraron en su
creación
también
su éxito seguirá dependiendo de más
robots ahora los de google que
lo verán y calificarán esta charla
solo para decidir si deberían
recomendarla a más casi campeones
así que si piensas
eso  Sería una buena idea que le digas a
esos robots directamente haciendo clic en el
botón Me gusta. Muchas
gracias
por
escuchar nuestra charla.